speak now to the leader of the labour
party sir keir starmak joining us from a
little bit further north secure lovely
to see you this morning um i hope you
were able just to listen into to a
little of what we were hearing from from
the government this morning in terms of
their response to the cost of living
crisis but can we be brutally honest no
matter whether it's a conservative prime
minister a labour prime minister monster
raving looney prime minister in downing
street at the moment no politician can
act to ameliorate all of the effects of
the cost of living crisis
well of course it's a difficult
situation i think we all appreciate that
but
you know today is a really significant
and worrying day
for millions of people because their
energy bills are going to go up by
hundreds of pounds and i've spoken to
people across the country
particularly those who are struggling
financially and they're really worried
about tossing and turning in their beds
about how they're going to pay for this
what we've said as the labour party is
look oil and gas companies in the north
sea have made more profit than they
expected because global prices have been
high therefore we should have a windfall
tax on that and use it to reduce those
energy bills by up to 600 pounds for
those that need it most so there's a
very practical plan on the table the
only plan on the table quite frankly
we've also said of all the times for the
government to decide to impose more tax
in national insurance now is the wrong
time it's the wrong tax it's the wrong
time and so
um i think
most people
are clear that when
you know the government really needed to
step up in that spring statement last
week they failed to do so and their
response is frankly pathetic on a very
very difficult day for millions and
millions of people energy bills going up
for you know more than we've ever seen
on record
you know people are really struggling
and i just don't think the government
gets it
yeah
just just though on the on the windfall
tax plan i mean this isn't the problem
yeah that was identified by pat mcfadden
your colleague when he was speaking to
me last week you can do it once so your
words are really important right now you
haven't said it in this interview but
you have said previously the windfall
tax plan would all but eliminates the
energy price rise for low-income
families pensioners and middle-income
families i mean
that might be true
now but it won't be true later on this
year when we see another set of price
rises
look it is a one-off tax um it's a
windfall tax but it would deal with the
immediate crisis and people waking up
today are asking the question
uh is there a plan on the table to deal
with the problem i've got right now
which is this rise in my prices uh
energy costs of hundreds of pounds and
they're seeing nothing from the
government the government says well you
can have a loan starting in october of
about two hundred pounds so six months
ago
this be paid back but my point is simply
this yeah
my point is simply this yeah the
windfall tanks that you're proposing
will give a break of a hunt a few
hundred pounds right now which will
frankly by my looking at the numbers be
utterly wiped out by the price rise that
we're all expecting come october
well there are two answers to that the
first is obviously there's got to be a
wide and medium a long-term strategy and
that's why we set out our energy
strategy last week which included
turbocharging renewables
fast forwarding on nuclear power but
importantly and significantly also
a project
to insulate homes and make them warmer
and i saw i'm up in manchester at the
moment last week i was in kirkleese and
i saw for myself council houses that
have already gone through that process
of insulation and i met the residents
there their bills are already very very
low because of that insulation program
led by a labour council that's the sort
of medium to long-term measure we need
so the labour party says we've got a
plan for dealing with the immediate
crisis
which is facing people today but we've
also got a plan for the longer term the
other thing i would add of course is
that you know as global prices stay high
that profit for the oil and gas
companies will be even higher probably
by the autumn than it is now but
contrast the labour party that's got a
practical plan to reduce bills now and
the government's pathetic response they
just don't get it they don't realize how
hard people are struggling just at the
moment
for a variety of reasons
with the government's plan to increase
tax and do nothing about these energy
prices okay but what in term okay in
terms then of benefits why does labour
not agree with with plenty of those
working uh you know in ngos at the
moment that benefits should not be
raised in line with inflation
well i think that that is something we
should look at because uh benefits have
fallen behind what what people wanted
from the government last week in that
spring state no no no no no i'm asking
you i'm asking you would you
as a point of principle would you
should look at
yeah would you i think
it's not it's not enough to say you're
going to look at i'm asking for a policy
commitment here would you increase in
line with inflation because if you don't
people on benefits experience a real
terms cut in the amount amount of money
that they have
yeah i think we've got to look at it for
that very reason because otherwise
people fall behind that's what we wanted
to see from the government last week
that's what we didn't see from the
government last week frankly if the
government put a package on the table
that parliament could agree we could get
on with this
but the government just doesn't get the
scale of the problem for millions of
millions of people
local elections coming up in five weeks
time also um and if people want to send
a message to the government to say um
britain deserves better than this your
response to the cost of living crisis is
pathetic this is the chance to do it
what labor is saying we've got a plan on
the table and we're we're on your side
we understand we take your worries
seriously
what about the minimum wage the rise
we're seeing today is is apparently the
third largest rise since the crash of
2008 some people are asking why it's not
the largest you know price the increase
in minimum wage that we've seen since
since 2008. it wasn't that long ago that
andy mcdonald resigned from the front
bench because you wouldn't agree to a
minimum wage of 15 pounds an hour i mean
isn't that something that the labour
party could as a progressive party get
behind right now that would have an
immediate effect
on the quality of life for many many
people
yeah what we put on the table at our
conference was an increase in the
minimum wage to
about 10 pounds as part of a package of
employment rights day one rights and i
can tell you this had that package been
in place had you had a labor government
taking seriously the security of people
at work you would not have had the
scandal of piano sucking 800 people in
the awful way that we they did the
government was on notice about that not
just because they had the memo the night
before the 800 were made redundant but
also because two years ago
we were saying to them if you don't act
on this minimum wage for seafarers
a company in the end is going to crash
through the gate and reduce
their replace their workforce with
agency workers on less than the minimum
wage that's exactly what has happened
two years ago the government said oh we
acknowledge that's a problem we'll look
at it okay they did nothing pno crashed
through the gate 800 people lost their
british public jobs that is is huge
so so do you generally believe the
british public are looking at what
labour is offering in contrast to the
government at the moment i i i'm
thinking this is a radical party this is
a party with big ideas an increase to
roughly 10 pounds and kind of
for the for the minimum wage your
one-off windfall tax that would cover
most of your price increases right now
but nothing for later on in the year
where's the invention
what i want people to
do is to look at the labour party and
see a party that understands their
worries that takes them
seriously and is prepared to put
practical plans on the paper on the
table people don't want a revolution
they do want to know how am i going to
pay my energy bill which has just gone
up today by hundreds of pounds we're
putting a practical plan on the paper on
the table it says for those that need it
most
you ask oil and gas companies who have
made more profit than they were
expecting to make because of the high
global prices we say ask those companies
to pay their fair share and that would
reduce those bills by 600 pounds so when
i'm talking to pensioners i was in
stevenage last week talking to
pensioners they weren't saying here we
want the revolution they were saying
here we really worried about our bill
one of the pensioners said to me that
they keep their heating on 12 degrees
because they think if they put it higher
than that
they can't afford the bill and this you
know people having to make a choice
between heating and eating i mean in
21st century britain what people want to
know is is the labour party does it
understand those worries and the answer
that is yes we do have we got a
practical solution to put on the table
to reduce those bills by up to 600
pounds yes we have contrast that with
the government where there was just a
pathetic response which isn't going to
help very many people at all and this is
the thing that people are talking about
all over the country and the question in
the end is
you know which party is on your side and
the labour party's on your side i just
want to conclude if we can by talking
about events in inverted commas and
around downing street carrie johnson you
seem to have suggested it should be
named if she is fined over partygate and
if that's the case should we then expect
to hear you know the next time your wife
gets a parking ticket
i think there's a huge difference
between um the situation of the wife of
the prime minister breaking the rules
made by the prime minister and any other
situation and i'm i'm not focusing on um
carrie here i actually do agree with the
general argument that the families of
politicians shouldn't be dragged in but
in and and therefore i focus
well rishi soon axe wife again i agree i
do agree with the general proposition
that
you know family members shouldn't be
brought into political arguments but so
far as the chancellor's wife is
concerned this is just a fundamental
question of principle here which is is
their household benefiting from money
made in russia when the government's put
in place sanctions that is in the public
interest for us to have an answer to i'm
not attacking um their family um i don't
agree with that way of doing politics
but i do want to know is the chanceless
household the chancellor's household
benefiting from money from a company
that's investing in russia when the
government is saying quite rightly
but nobody should be doing that
sanctions should be in place and we
should particularly in the dreadful
situation in ukraine frankly be doing
everything we can not just to
make life more difficult in russia but
to [ __ ] their ability to function so
it's not a personal attack i don't agree
with that i absolutely don't agree with
that but i do think that i would have
thought the chance would actually want
to come clean on this and say actually i
can be very very clear that my household
doesn't benefit from any money that's
come in any way from russia
during this invasion of ukraine it's a
simple question i think you should just
answer it actually help his wife have
you just answered that question
um secure stamina we have to leave it
there because i have to admit it sounds
like the breakfast rush might be
starting just just over your shoulder
there secure stamina thanks very much
for joining us appreciate it
thank you